-The game works
exactly like Pictionary,
except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets,
and they're drawing
in a 3-D space
using a program called
Tilt Brush.
We will be able to see
their point of view
on the big screen upstage.
You get 45 seconds per turn.
I will go first.
You guys can all
take your seats.
You can sit there, bud.
-Whew.
-Alright, here we go.
Kristen, are you good
at Pictionary?
-I'm such a bad drawer.
-Perfect, uh, alright, good.
Okay, oh, wait, I need to do
something first, right?
Alright, give me --
give me a number.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
One guy just said three.
Here we go.
Okay, alright.
Okay.
Alright, so, it's a person.
How's that?
-What...
-What's going on?
-Woman, maybe.
-Oh, my God.
-The devil!
[ Laughter ]
Um...
-What?
-Hands.
-I don't ever want
to meet this person.
Is it Donkey from "Shrek"?
-I'm like, "Is it me?"
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-He's just saying "Ooh?"
-Yeah, kind of.
-Ooh.
Wait.
-Ooh?
-"Oh?"
-He's saying...
[ Laughter ]
Kristen, I need a guess,
anything at all.
-[ Laughter ]
[ Sour note plays ]
-It's a werewolf.
-I'm awful at this.
I'm sorry. I'm so sorry.
-What is it?
-It's supposed to be a werewolf.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that was --
see, that was --
You did a great job.
I did not.
-Thank you.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
-Yeah, I have a one-track mind.
I'm like, "The Devil.
The Devil. The Devil."
-Gaten, you're up.
-Ahh.
-I'm nervous.
-No, don't be nervous.
-I might pee.
[ Laughter ]
-I already did, so you got
to think of something original.
-I have a large head.
-Oh, before you put that on,
Gaten, pick a number.
-It's light.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Nine's my -- nine is my lucky
number.
-I like nine.
-Nine is my lucky number.
I don't know why.
-Is it your birthday or
something?
-No.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep.
-Okay, no, that's not bad.
That's not bad.
-Good luck.
-No.
-You got this.
-Sorry, dude, alright.
-Sorry, man.
Alright, here we go.
-Okie dokie.
Okay, can I start?
Yeah, I can start? Okay.
-Go.
-Oh, it's an object.
It's, like, an object,
so you know.
-Okay.
-Okay, and then...
-Oh...
-Wait, wait, not done yet.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Tariq, how come
you're not guessing?
-Um...
Okay, it's, um, uh...
Is it, like, oh, my God, a
termite thing?
-What? No!
No.
I don't know what else to do.
-Walk around it.
-An ant farm.
-Make it three-dimensional.
-An ant farm. A hamster wheel.
-Yeah!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Yeah!
-We do this!
-How did they get that?
-How did you get that?
-No idea how he got that.
-That is insane --
a termite in a hamster wheel.
-The synergy, man.
Synergy, bro. Come on.
-Alright you're up.
Kristen, you're up.
-There's nowhere to go
from here but up.
-For sure.
-I just want to say --
"werewolf" is not a person.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know what I mean?
I was like...
-I agree with you.
-Alright.
-It's like a character.
-Mythical figure.
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
-Werewolf.
-Cool, so I drew an action.
That's fun.
I'm gonna draw this action.
-Drawing this action's
gonna be really fun.
-I'm gonna look so cool doing
it, too, ready?
-You look so --
-Here we go.
-You look cool
doing anything, bud.
-Okay, so it's...
-It's an action, okay.
It's a person.
They have a hand.
They're waving.
They're giving out tickets.
Candy bars.
They are chopping something.
They are -- that can't be --
that can't be it.
What is happening?
-Wait, wait.
-Alright, they're happy.
A beard.
They have a beard, and they're
holding something.
A candy bar, a microphone.
Is it Santa Claus?
-[ Groans ]
-Is it paper?
"1, 2, 3," on it.
-Uh, actually, it's both.
-It's a numbers runner.
-No, wait, it's --
-Oh, okay, no, it's a teacher.
A teacher with an eraser.
A teacher with a --
with a-a-a-- ice cream.
A-A Klondike bar.
It's a bearded teacher!
Is it, uh, Bill from, uh --
uh, what's that game?
[ Sour note plays ]
-Oh, gosh.
-Do we win by default?
-I just started cheating.
-It was an action.
What was it?
-A selfie, you know what I mean?
-Ah, man.
-Wow.
-That was good.
That was good. I'm sorry.
-Okay, okay.
I mean,
do I even need to get up?
I mean, I feel like --
I feel like we won regardless.
-But here's the thing, Tariq.
You think you won, but
I just heard from the booth.
This final round
is worth 1,000 points.
-Oh, come on.
-Whoever wins this
wins the whole game.
-Okay.
-Alright, so here's
the way it works --
-So, wait, if I lose, you win?
-That's correct.
That's the way it is.
-Why?
-That's just the way life works.
Gaten, you have to grow up
sometime, buddy. I'm sorry.
-He's all grown up.
-So, Tariq, you're gonna do it,
but we're all gonna guess.
-Oh.
-Okay.
-So whoever guesses wins.
-Oh.
-Okay, cool, sweet.
-Okay.
-Alright, what number?
-Uh, I'm going, mm...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
One. I'm going one.
I'm going one.
-Here you go. Good luck.
-Mm. Mm!
This is...
-Come on. We got this.
We can still get the win.
-...a movie.
-Do you guys know what it is?
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I heard, like, "Oh..."
-Yeah.
Is it an action?
What is it, Tariq?
-It's a person in a film.
-Oh.
-Got to pull the trigger, Tariq,
and start drawing.
-Shut up.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it's an oval.
It's a potato.
It's not a potato.
-That's an angry man.
-A vampire -- Dracula.
-That's, uh, Frankenstein?
It's, uh -- what?
-It's ears.
-A ghost!
It's Casper -- isn't that --
-Oh, a lot of hair.
-Oh, Beetlejuice?
-The Joker?
-Is it Rick
from "Rick and Morty"?
-The Joker!
-Ah! Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Was it?
No, what did you say?
What is it?
-Joker?
We got it -- Joker!
-No!
-I love it! Kristen Stewart --
the best, my partner.
We got the win.
Kristen Stewart,
Gaten Matarazzo, Tariq Trotter.